okay I think that after you've got it so
let me for the rest of you who are
taking a bit longer which is fine let me
walk through it again okay because I
only really did one example with the
quadrants and showing kind of positive
negative way okay so here's the first
thing I know I've got to deal with this
cause it most business right so what is
the range restriction on cos inverse
you're not apply it right not is
inclusive not apply okay so that tells
me I must be in the first or second
quadrant okay so now what I draw my
thing here right see first or second
okay and the second thing I notice is
that cause of this angle is going to
give me minus 15 and 17 so it causes
actually negative so which of these two
quadrants am i interested in answer
quadrant two okay so now I've got that
now I can draw a triangle in okay and
I've got cause if I put feeder in here
it's gonna be adjacent on hypotenuse so
that's minus 15 on 17 okay by the way in
case you're wondering it's - we're
taking them going to the left like
x-axis yeah and so if I'm coming here me
down okay right so it's um it's a
Pythagorean triad so it's an eight 15 17
triangle with that with that money okay
so therefore sine of theta is just eight
on 17 oh is it negative or positive and
you know it is positive because I'm in
the second quadrant which sine is
positive okay now this is interesting
um sorry cuz of us here positive was a
tenuous positive sign cause reverse also
positive so I haven't really seen a case
where it actually goes negative okay so
let's just quickly for the sake of it do
one tan of coziness
okay so again I'm from from north of
mine okay so I'm first or second
quadrant here and then cos is negative
again so I'll be the second quadrant
/ yeah there's my feed oh so close is -
three or four so I've got my minus three
here and my for their adjacent opposite
that's right adjacent on an iPod
so by the way don't get fooled it's up
it's three quarters right so it's not a
nice fire so what is the hypotenuse in
this case this is uh yes so this is 16
wait 16 months like so you get return
yeah yep okay so now for a tan that's
opposite on adjacent opposite adjacent
but I need a second portrait right where
10 is negative okay so it's going to be
minus 3/7 on three so this is one of the
cases where a good lady okay
now if you just think that come on call
me on this because I didn't explain it
before I said you know when I was doing
this diagram yeah and I just said yeah
I'm just gonna take cause of both sides
and I'm not gonna claim why I can't do
that even though we've explained why
sometimes you can't okay I want you to
come back to these six identities that
we came up with okay this is the reason
why I remember them we have been
thinking all this time about positives
and negatives about sign okay now these
six identities actually include really
important information about the side of
each of these combinations okay for
instance have a look at this guy
okay and by extension this one okay you
actually already know without knowing
anything about the value of x what the
sign of this combination will be is it
going to be positive or negative it must
be positive right because we said this
is the top half of the unit circle right
it's a square root but by definition we
define it as positive which is why you
can take sine of cos inverse of a
positive or sine of cos inverse of a
negative you always come out positive
okay now these aren't the only ones that
are like that which is the other one you
see
it's out is this way isn't it okay this
one is also always positive okay that's
interesting that was um that was this
kiss yeah okay can you see why that's
going to be when you go tan inverse
right tenuous what was the restriction
on tan inverse minus plants you up to
plan to right but in those two quadrants
the cause is always positive right you
see what's going on here so in some
senses you don't need to worry about
that okay so I'm trying to draw the
connection between drawing these
quadrants and the restrictions the
domain and range restrictions be made of
these okay so one two three regardless
of what we get what ratio you have a key
whether it's positive you you're always
going to get a positive at the end okay
you can verify that when you calculate
off on the other hand have a look at the
other three three what's going to happen
well again this favorite is just
positive all the time
so really the decisive factor will be
this guy or this guy or this guy right
so if I said ten of sine inverse of
something negative whatever it is in
here this is going to be negative right
does it mean negative one positive okay
we're from a tan of cos inverse of a
positive I can know for sure this
thing's going to be positive QC so the
sine of this whole ratio function
depends on the sine of X in those cases
okay and this was an example see you can
of course you must have a negative
that's this one here okay so this ratio
is negative so the whole thing is
nothing new okay so key Seaver